pr
2020年考えたことというのはやっぱりなんといっても
こらですが今コロナを超えず新しい世界は人間中心写真
地球と人間が共に生きている社会を作りた
そういう動いいうそれぞれの人たちの職業の中で頑張りたい私は正拳塾とか環境とかと
いうものでありますけれども
茶園リストはまだ違った形で新しい剤を黒車演奏考えてられるこれからは
カーク技術芸ずの際です
今はれるように経済力が大きい人がだけが大きな顔してるんじゃなし
3:00しても a 5函パーチェスともそして勇者も
ぬんだとともにいながら新しい世界が女らしいから出ればこの地球で駅伝蹴ることは
ダイヤの月
安いと思います
2020年これからまたスター部していく21円
新しい世界に希望がなければなりません
自由と勇気のある人たち
昔はお金が設けスはよかったかと犬でももう大した良かったなと言われますけれども
そうじゃなくっ
何より無駄がなかったらいけないのは病気ですその勇気が新しい世界を必ずキレイ焼い
て6つならば多くの触覚に自分の身の回りのことから幽居
車
しかし一方
新してほしいそした地球に祝い80を打ちか法人康和いるわけですから
必ず地球の中で共に生きていく姿を目指すことができるのではないかと思っています
いが好評で展覧会をしています
地球は回る
地球は一つ
というちょいめしのためにこの建物は円形です
円形がが戦場にナイフなら専用に何か訳では円形になっている技でもなるんですけれど
も
ここに来ると
自分たち中身体の中いい
感じてくるんだ地球の中に生きてるんだというほどを感じてくるようなかけも多いした
よ
虫上から光が入ってきます周りから自らまだ反射の光が入っています
水素止まると水は飛び込んできます
send 共に生きているようなことを考えながらそして今度は中にあるん
現代技術という非常に難しい道言われているものですけれども
人々は極限の状態で考え続けたものは点在していると
これを見てですねよし自分も生活の中で何か考えてやろうと大きい小さいは関係あり
ません
それでまたそれがずーっと座ってきたら
広州から
世界の中心になっていくんじゃないか欧州から中国の中心
中国の中心が世界の上司になってそこへ人々1人ずつが参加できればいいなというよう
な展覧会ですから
安積に来ていただいてああ
10なんか分からなかったなぁと面白かったなーという人たちが色々いるんですけども
自分がどう考えるかと自分がどう感じるかと思ってやって来ていただければ幸いです
者がいい
展覧会のことですけれども
やっぱり人間は挑戦じゃないかと思っていますか
このながら早く完全に非常に属しないと困るんですけれどもこれを超えてまた新しい
世界を作って行かなければ
左手甲にあります人語
こう言うというのは三勝
学生際にをご人たちは自分の dj はこういうふうに送りたいと思う
こういう人生を送りたいなということを変えなきゃいけたと思うんですけどね
その時の雄大に重大なわけだよ
こころティナ青いリーグですこの青いリウムを
航路の中でも実上で100歳まで
いって欲しいと思いますそのためには
胸腺というところが必要なんですけれどもからなず難しいことが起こっています
願いのコーナーの問題も
考えるのやがったことは思う
dj の中では考えてもみなかったことがたくさん起こるわけですけれどもそれを
乗り越えている時にまた新しい
が媚びてるのか感動は思うんですけどゲージというのはもちろん建築もないんです
けれども
小いう世界を
作らればならない
同議員は回相談には小さいカフェんもんでもある程度の中規模の建物でもすべての
建築に
そうゆうきゃんすがあるのです
そのことを忘れる自分の子の名がをいつも
一方電信一歩前進もっと前進するかなるもんだよ
そしたらそれを乗り越えでまた
新しい問題が多いしかし平成はそういうもんだんです
しかしそれを保つためには20代30代の時に
面白いことに挑戦して心バックアップしておけば
4まで高靭性百選はへーバー各受けるのではないかと
用法に思っていますから
笑う展覧会のあちこちにある
模型を見たり失明を見たりしながら
ああの時アウトはあそこで失敗したんだなと
あこっちも失敗してるなぁとしかしまだ生きてるじゃないかと
また挑戦しているじゃないかというのを見ていただくと面白いではないかと
僕の人たちがそれを見ながらお互いに話し合っ
の建築はダメだったなとこの現実はダメだったなぁと言いながら自分たちならば好勝負
ということを考える機会になれば
学生達だけ話380歳の人にも共有歳の人にも面白い点長いんだものではないかと思っ
ています
[拍手]